across the globe there have been reports  of  small tremors and power outages all  centering from a single point of origin  in london we have received hundreds of  reports of flashing neon lights in the  sky across the city  it is clear that it is centered here  where the military are now focusing  their efforts  to set up some kind of investigation we  [Music]  we've reached the target we've got  movement at 12 o'clock  it's an arcade console do not engage  central we have a big problem  fear has washed over london tonight  it is anticipated that more quarantine  areas will pop  up as this unknown contagion continues  to spread  mainframe true how can we stop it  [Music]  it's time to wake up people  and there is nothing to fear and there  is nothing to fear